o lado pessoal de quem fala andar que
sejam muito bem vindos vem cá meu bem
você é expetável eu os trato de que 33
jogos dos rap que os relacionados na
internet xbox rex lazo o primeiro jogo
chama só assim é que é possível
surpreender mas com as regras
estamos com um pai também está só vejo
que encontrarem uma cerca qual a uma
cerca muito bem por ser injusta faca num
âmbito não é logicamente consistente
olha aí ó ó lobos que possuímos num
pântano isto não faz sentido nenhum e
não faz olha já encontrou um piso as
suas boas votar fala vai ficar alheio
vários emmy e globo é o godói não
aconteça vamos passar pelo rio e ei bom
mas vou lá e contraí já estou iremos
falar em casa tem um fogo lá dentro
bruno é isso que está na estação canadá
onde transitou youtube ainda casa o
botafogo e fogo mesmo esse é um defeito
fu queiram olha aí o rio burra que cada
um fosse gaúcho é tão assustadora que o
cheque olha só posso ficar parado e tudo
muito assustador vamos fugir vamos
apanhar mais linhas tão divertido neste
lugar não só beijar a cruz foi atrás na
é numa melo ainda está muito perto e
lento mas ao mesmo tempo é rápido porque
porque tornar as voltas de léo
aproveitou metade isso ao nunca entrem
dentro de uma floresta à procura de
cebolas sabem por que esse volume não
achem florestas porque tinha estúpida
stock light recuperar o investimento
bairro eu acho que eu votar contra não é
porque eu voltar atrás será que eu tenho
que salvar um burro talento da casa não
sei que já não encontra as bombas
nenhuma jóia masturbe da casa caralhos
domingo alguém aí entrou a mãe ou o pai
que mesmo lá encontrei supostamente
blues brilho nem coisa nenhuma nenhuma
meu deus porque gosto de histórias com
414 muito fácil muito fácil ou uma boca
cinco já tem 600 mil ta mais rápido
botafogo aí está a cantar a música eu já
ficaram com o japão está aqui é muito
perto fosse [ __ ] e outras bola depois
de meia hora encontrei mais uma
cebolinha quatro luas que está muito
feliz né
não não sai tanto apertar perto da
pequena área o que é isto que estou
presenciaram da moto é israel está muito
rápido que outros roma como é que eu não
me está pouco 7 fábula eu vou ser a
prosseguir sair um pouco sozinho estou
junto com a mesma traz mendonça teve
pouca oferta a quase dengue mas não vou
deixar
porque é isso um jogo dos reds chama-se
shrek e insistiu com custos agradável
visualmente cedo preto ou não isso é
quando joguei só está em tornar se torna
óbvia da [ __ ]
vamos ver de biópsia falar muito ao país
o pessoal este gráfico sim isso é
gostoso olhem só folha em 2d e flores em
2d muito bonito muito estranho porque eu
tô ouvindo mil de gritar o povo jogar
assim agora fato grid para a nokia
porque tem culpa da música eu precisava
seguir o caminho é baixo e joão mário
godinho de flor de macieira muito muito
má é bastante entre mineiro impiedoso
pára de gritar o nome do show que o
feijão se eu que ganhei um feijãozinho -
grita caramba eu não sou eu tenho como
ir cada vez mais perto [ __ ] aí a fora
desse jogo sobre o mesmo da merda mesmo
[ __ ] atacante fred 2 é o próximo jogo
podem ver pessoal o menino estava
bastante futurista é por aí tem um item
o que discutir
essa música é para tirar produção porque
têm copyrights é que esta merda pô
ai que só seria capaz de executar alguém
dentro da casa que é que o juro porque
em 2012 haverá um show com marcos feito
louco jataí e supostamente devia lançar
cordas né porque se encurta contato
funciona turma tá ai ai eu não sou seu
amigo está tudo bem passado no rio
descobrir um banco dentro de um jogo no
lugar não é a intenção
ai ai ai ai ai
i salvar o colega
sério eu respiro em uma nuvem em cima de
seu próximo rival
2 só espero que vocês não está destruído
onde faz isso perde em vídeos em boneca
que está aí pra fazer nenhum estado já
sabem o quanto eu vou falar em favorito
e cuidado coxa
valeu